well hey there's jay happ
cardinal they made a deal and they got
jay happ from the minnesota twins
and they gave john gant to the twins
wade leblanc is
looking for his first career win against
the twins
six career appearances three starts
against minnesota
and he is all in one but the lefty kind
of settled things down for the cardinals
when they needed him most
well yeah that's what he does that's
what he's been doing his whole career
he's been solid
not overpowering but one of those guys
who just goes out and gets
his job done one arm with one out for
the twins leblanc with the 1-2 pitch a
long look to first the pitch swung on
and missed
off speed pitch down and away strikes
out garber most of the time the stuff
you hear about never comes to fruition
it's usually the stuff behind the scenes
that nobody knows about
and you can take a look at leblanc's
change up right here and this is a good
one now the cleanup batter
trevor larnick one and all the count the
swings hits a ground ball to short right
field against the shift
tommy edmond throws him out so that
takes care of the twins with a single
fly-out strikeout and a ground out
against the ship right-hander griffin
jacks and this was a start supposed to
be made by
jose burrell's but obviously that didn't
happen the twins has a backup plan in
the event barrios was traded had jacks
with the team and now three in one to
dylan carlson this one a line drive into
right field that's going to be caught by
learning coming in
reaching out he makes the call and the
catch and carlson retired
one album so one down and now paul
goldschmidt swing at a missed strike
three
not a good cut on a jack's breaking bowl
goldschmidt look
like that well done griffin jack's first
strikeout tonight two out
goldschmidt's not going to swing like
that too often so he was thinking for
something else he reached badly for that
timing off good pitch there tyler
o'neill now behind two balls and no
strikes and the pitch is swinging a fly
ball into right field larnick with the
play
will pollen catch near the track and
that's the inning st louis doesn't score
gets a hit leaves one after one with two
outs
runner in scoring position and it's
going to be up to andrew tim simmons 1-0
to simmons and a ball line to left and a
base hit
sono being waved around third and he
will score
and the twins get a two-out hit from
andrewton simmons to take the first lead
nice hitting there by andrea simmons and
this is what you don't see when you hit
eighth in the national league
you don't see a little spin and breaking
ball or half a cutter kind of thing
right in the middle of the plate but
simmons takes advantage of it gets an
rbi and puts his team ahead
captain jackson a spot start for a
former twin jose barrios
and a breaking ball we'll wrap that at
that up for jacks his second strikeout
went away here is dylan carlson it'll
line her to right his first time up
sono right behind the bag to the bag
two down aronado will back and the 1-2
pitch has popped up
behind the plate garver he's got room
flips the mask away on the grass he's
got it and that's out number three
so jacks three scoreless innings st
louis leaves one
cardinals that may be in business here
with bader at the plate infield in with
the ball in the outfield
and he does vader with a high fly ball
in two left brooker with the catch
o'neal tagging up
and the game is tied harrison boehner
ties it up
sac fly into left and he drives in his
26th
here's the pitch that's lying to the
shark stop to young
off the bat of miguel cino even the best
players are going to give a little bit
and i wish we had a better angle you
could kind of see
exactly where it was coming from the
other side but you can't
fault goldie in that situation because
that is a broken wrist
waiting to happen that's why leblanc has
been careful with ceno here's nick
gordon
popped up on the infield leblanc
will make the catch athlete right there
look at that play
all over that chevy call to the pen and
the cardinals turn it over to ryan
hellsley he has been tremendous
with inherited runners and now it's max
kepler
outside corner and struck him out good
work by
helsley the base hit simmons and then
the strikeout
paul goldschmidt leading off the sixth
inning tyler duffy is the new pitcher
get up the middle base head into center
well for the criticals
that is just their third hit and it's
hit number 1500
in the career paul goldschmidt 1500 hits
now the crowd
acknowledges hit number 1500 for paul
goldsmith
here in the bottom of the sixth tommy
edmond does have a grand slam in his
career
364 with the bases loaded in the 1-2
pitch
edmond it is fair inside the right field
line
two runs will score here comes another
throw to the plate not in time
tommy edmond clears the bases
cardinals on top 4-1 so really good at
that by tommy edmond
a little jumpy on the first breaking
ball didn't see the first fastball so
what does he do like he always does he
slows himself down
he gets a bad bad pitch as a breaking
ball to him i think
especially in the strike zone and just
does what you're supposed to do with it
just hit a line
drive you don't try to do too much in
that situation and what a huge at-bat
and especially
hitting a double right there with
harrison bader on first base you know
he's coming around to score nolan
arenado cardinals two for six with
runners in scoring position
and the one base hit into right
here comes goldie the wave of men the
throw to the plate
as they miss the cut they'll throw
behind nolan aronado he's in a rundown
and they avoid the tag but he's out of
the baseline
the run will score a nice insurance run
good base running
by goldschmidt and arenado comes through
and coming on the pitch in the ninth
inning the cardinal closer and all-star
alex reyes i think it's interesting that
alex reyes is going to start the inning
in a non-saved situation
and you know maybe you wouldn't do that
if you didn't have the three batter
minimum
in play think about that if you maybe
you could bring in tj mcfarland but if
you gave up a base runner then you bring
in alex
okay that's that's fine but uh you have
to have him face three and that's kind
of playing with fire a little bit if
your other reliever pitching in the
ninth inning doesn't have a good day so
i think that's why he's just going with
alex here grace pitches to andrewton
simmons and the 1-2 in the air out to
left
tyler o'neal now the cardinals can hold
on
they go back above the 500 mark
the 1-2 pitch here to jake cave ground
ball to the third baseman playing like a
shortstop with the shift on and
aronado throws him out two gone the
twins are down to their last out
three out of four tonight for jorge
polanco here's the one strike pitch
a high fly ball down the left field line
o'neal moves over
and makes the catch in fair territory
for a red bird winner
a fly out to left for polanco and this
ball game has come to an end
after beating the twins 5-1